"Game-of-Thrones"-Freunde,
das epische "Lied von Eis und Feuer"
geht in die nächste Runde.
Denn HBO präsentiert uns gerade
das Prequel "House of the Dragon".
Autor George R.R. Martin
versprach jede Menge Drachen-Power.
Weil sie im Fokus der Serie stehen.
Ich habe mir dabei gedacht:
Drachen, come on.
Fliegen, Feuer spucken,
geht das wirklich?
*dramatische Musik*
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Heute mit einem weiten Blick
über die Landschaft.
Wir sind auf der Burg Kriebstein,
um uns "Game-of-Thrones"-Feeling
in die Folge zu holen.
Ich muss zugeben, ich bin ganz froh,
dass von hinten nicht gleich
ein riesiger Drache kommt.
Aber genau die schauen wir uns heute
etwas genauer an.
Wie immer
mache ich das nicht allein.
Sondern mit meinem Lieblings-Tierarzt
Dr. Karim Montasser.
Karim ist absoluter Fan
vom "Lied von Eis und Feuer".
Das geht sogar soweit, dass sein WLAN
zuhause "WLAN Morghulis" heißt.
Zudem kennt er sich aus
mit Tieren in der realen Welt.
Somit ist er die perfekte Besetzung
für die heutige Folge.
Karim, valar Morghulis.
- Valar Dohaeris.
Schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Wir haben schon
eine Folge zusammen gemacht.
Damals
zu den "Phantastischen Tierwesen".
Den Link findet ihr hier oben.
Du sagtest,
du schaust das wegen deiner Frau.
Nun ist es anders.
Nun bin ich der Fan
und habe auch Ahnung von der Sache.
Sehr gut.
Du hast es durchgesuchtet?
V.a. die Bücher.
Ich bin Mega-Fan.
Ich glaube immer noch,
dass "Winds of Winter" erscheint.
Mein Herz ist bisher halb gebrochen.
Warst du nicht zufrieden
mit dem Ende der Serie?
Lass uns doch vielleicht
über Drachen reden.
Gut.
Die sollen bei "House of the Dragon"
im Fokus der Serie stehen.
Ich finde das spannend.
Denn Drachen kommen in vielen Sagen,
Mythen und Fantasy-Geschichten vor.
Aber nicht
bei uns in der realen Welt.
Bevor wir checken,
was von ihnen echt sein könnte,
wollen wir einen Blick
auf die Fiktion werfen.
Wie sind die Drachen
bei George R.R. Martin dargestellt?
Dafür haben wir
Film-Experten rangeholt.
Nämlich die netten Leute
von "Cinema Strikes Back".
Sie präsentieren uns
feurige Fiktions-Fakten.
Hi, Marius.
Hi, Jack, wir sprechen zwar immer
von Drachen bei "Game of Thrones".
Aber richtig reinrassig
sind die nicht.
In vielen mythologischen
Darstellungen rund um die Welt
sind Drachen
feuerspeiende vierbeinige Kreaturen.
In der Serie sehen wir aber,
dass sie nur 2 Beine haben.
Und die Flügel,
auf denen sie auch laufen können.
George R.R. Martin
hat sich also Mischwesen ausgedacht.
Aus Drachen und Wyvern.
Wyvern haben in den Mythen
2 Beine, Flügel wie eine Fledermaus,
und ihr Biss ist giftig,
aber sie können kein Feuer speien.
Danke, Marius.
Egal, ob es
Richtung Drache oder Wyvern geht.
Sie sehen aus wie geflügelte Echsen.
Wenn ich mir
auf Instagram echte Drachen ansehe,
taucht als Erstes immer der auf.
Der Panzer-Gürtelschweif
sieht aus wie ein Drache.
Er ist auch süß,
aber das Bild täuscht.
Denn im Original
ist er nur 10 cm groß.
So klein?
Wenn es um Größe geht, habe ich noch
den Komodowaran mitgebracht.
Er ist auf jeden Fall größer und
heißt im Englischen "Komodo dragon".
Die sind auch furchterregend.
Sie sind aber
nicht so groß wie ein Drache.
Ich finde,
Echsen sind die richtige Richtung.
Und wenn ich Echsen sage,
stelle ich eine Frage.
*spannende Musik*
Das ist eine Frage,
die stellt sich zuerst ein Tierarzt.
Aber sie macht Sinn,
weil Echsen immer kaltblütig sind.
Sie produzieren nicht selber Wärme,
sie sind auf die Sonne angewiesen.
Das sieht man auch, wenn sie morgens
auf Steinen in der Sonne rumliegen
und Wärme für den Tag auftanken.
Bevor sie losflitzen können,
brauchen sie diese Energie.
Wir sagten, dass Drachen
die Merkmale von Echsen haben.
Sie haben Schuppen statt Fell
und legen Eier.
Sie müssten also kaltblütig
oder richtiger wechselwarm sein.
Das würde auch deshalb Sinn machen,
weil wechselwarme Tiere
die ganze Energie, die sie sparen,
in Körpermasse stecken können.
Drachen haben sehr viel Körpermasse,
und sie wachsen immer weiter.
Deshalb würde es passen.
Ja, das passt auch gut
zu "Game of Thrones".
Denn dort heißt es ja,
die Drachen kommen aus Valyria,
einem Land
zwischen 14 aktiven Vulkanen.
Auch genannt
"Land of the Long Summer".
Da ist es also ordentlich warm.
Aber es heißt
nicht nur "Song of Fire",
sondern auch "and Ice".
Und Kälte und wechselwarme Tiere
funktioniert nicht.
Denn Muskeln funktionieren
durch chemische Reaktionen.
Die funktionieren viel besser,
wenn es warm ist.
Deshalb wärmen wir uns
vor dem Sport auch auf.
Bei wechselwarmen Tieren
ist es sogar so krass,
dass sie sich z.T.
gar nicht bewegen können,
wenn es zu kalt ist,
und deshalb Winterschlaf halten.
Dann haut das mit dem Wechselwarm
nicht so gut hin.
Wir sehen die Drachen in Staffel 7
auch jenseits der Mauer,
richtig in Schnee und Eis.
Da ist es nicht so,
dass sie Winterschlaf halten.
Sie bewegen sich nicht nur,
sie kämpfen richtig.
Wobei es für einen von denen
nicht so gut ausgeht.
*Der Drache schreit.*
Viserion, rest in peace.
Das bedeutet aber, wir wissen klar,
dass Drachen warmblütig sein müssen.
Das heißt aber auch,
sie haben einen hohen Energiebedarf.
Um die ganze Masse zu versorgen.
Dann sind sie entweder
dauernd am Essen oder krass hungrig.
Da möchte ich nicht im Weg stehen.
Aber Drachen
haben nun mal dieses Äußere.
Sie sind so schuppig-echsig.
Hast du irgendeine Behelfslösung,
dass es trotzdem geht?
Bei den Echsen
einen einzigen, den Teju.
Der ist krass.
Er 1,70 m lang, 10 kg schwer.
Und er kann seine Körpertemperatur
willentlich hochfahren bis zu 10°C
über die Umgebungstemperatur.
Natürlich in der Paarungszeit.
Die Natur und die sexy time,
das hatten wir in der letzten Folge.
Wenn wir von den Echsen weg
zu den Säugetieren gehen,
gibt es welche,
die zumindest die Optik haben.
Das Schuppentier und das Gürteltier.
Sie sehen aus wie Drachen,
sind aber nur so groß wie ein Hund.
Na gut, aber es wäre
zumindest eine Annäherung.
Dann können wir erstmal festhalten,
die Drachen von Daenerys
sind warmblütig,
können damit wahrscheinlich
aber keine Echsen sein.
Sie sind vielmehr große, fliegende,
feuerspuckende Schuppentiere.
*spannende Musik*
Ich habe das mit der fliegenden Echse
einfach so gesagt.
Aber wenn man genauer nachdenkt,
ist es krass,
dass so ein Riesentier abheben
und fliegen soll.
Das Größte,
was wir in der realen Welt haben,
ist der Wander-Albatros.
Er wiegt 7 kg und hat
eine Flügel-Spannweite von 3,50 m.
Das ist beachtlich.
Ich habe mal in Neuseeland gesehen,
wie ein Albatros abhebt.
Sie sind so schwer,
dass sie erstmal so laufen,
bevor sie in die Luft gehen.
Bei "Game of Thrones"
starten die Drachen genauso.
Sie watscheln erstmal so lang.
Trotzdem ist ein Albatros
nur ein Bruchteil von einem Drachen.
Da müssen wir nochmal überlegen,
von welchen Dimensionen wir sprechen.
Da muss uns Marius nochmal helfen.
Wie groß werden die Viecher?
Der größte Drache,
den wir kennen, ist Balerion.
Das ist der Drache, dessen Feuer
den Iron Throne schmiedete.
Er wurde gute 200 Jahre alt.
Und da Drachen bei "Game of Thrones"
immer weiterwachsen,
auch dementsprechend groß.
Man sagt,
Balerion konnte zum Schluss
einen Auerochsen
mit einem Mal runterschlucken.
Dafür konnte er
aber kaum noch fliegen.
Wie groß die Drachen von Dany sind,
sieht man in dieser Szene gut.
Nach George R.R. Martin hat Drogon
hier eine Flügelspannweite von 7 m
und sieht etwa so groß aus
wie ein Elefant.
Danke, Marius.
Es scheint auch in der Fiktion
eine Grenze fürs Fliegen zu geben.
Lass uns bei Drogon bleiben.
Eine Flügel-Spannweite von 7 m,
ist die irgendwie realistisch?
Das hängt etwas davon ab,
was für Flügel wir betrachten.
Es gibt Flügel bei Vögeln,
einfach Knochen mit Federn dran.
Und dann
gibt es Flügel bei Fledermäusen.
Die sind
viel interessanter und cooler.
Denn Fledermäuse
haben 5 Finger im Flügel,
zwischen denen
eine Membran gespannt ist.
Diese Finger können sie
unabhängig voneinander bewegen.
Das macht diese Flugmanöver möglich.
Auch, dass sie kopfüber
an der Decke landen können.
Cool, dass sie das können.
Denn wenn man so ein Bild umdreht
von kopfüberhängenden Fledermäusen,
ergibt sich die coolste Band,
die je existiert hat.
Ich nenne sie liebevoll
die "Bat Street Boys".
♪ Bat Street's bat ...
♪ ... allright.
Sie faszinieren
auch die Wissenschaft.
U.a. schaut man sich Fledermäuse an
für die nächste Generation Drohnen.
Wissenschaftler der Brown University
haben mit CGI-ähnlicher Technik
ein Computermodell
des Fledermaus-Flugs entwickelt.
Da sieht man gut, wie flexibel
die Flügel einer Fledermaus sind.
Deshalb würde ich den Award
für das schnellstfliegende Tier
an diese Fledermaus geben.
Sie erreicht 160 km/h.
Und ja, alle Vogel- und Falken-Fans,
der Wanderfalke erreicht 320 km/h.
Aber das ist halt
kontrolliertes Fallen.
Das finde ich nicht so beachtlich.
- Das kann jeder.
Die Fledermaus
kann 160 km/h im freien Flug
und in den Manövern erreichen,
das ist viel beachtlicher.
Deshalb ist diese kontroverse Szene,
in der ein Drache abgeschossen wird,
wirklich Schwachsinn.
Warum sollte Rhaegal
sich abschießen lassen,
wenn er sich wegbewegen kann?
Lass uns davon ausgehen,
Drachen haben so fledermausähnliche
Flügel und Flugmechanik.
Dann ist die Frage,
wie groß können Fledertiere werden?
Nicht so riesig.
Das Größte, was wir real haben,
ist der Goldkronen-Flughund
mit 1,50-1,70 m Flügel-Spannweite.
Aber das ist ja
doch ordentlich.
Der ist dann so breit
wie ich groß bin.
Aber wiegt nur 1 kg.
Da passt unsere Analogie
dann nicht mehr so ganz.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wenn wir es also
ins Verhältnis setzen
und nochmal Drogon betrachten,
dürfte dieser max. 4,5 kg wiegen.
Das haut nicht hin, selbst, wenn man
etwas Toleranz mit einrechnet.
Wir sollten uns mit den Flugsauriern
wirklichen Schwergewichten zuwenden.
Die gab es in allen möglichen
Größen, Formen und Farben.
U.a. so 25 cm bis hin
zum Quetzalcoatlus northropi.
Er hatte
eine Flügelspannweite von 12 m.
Damit ist er größer als Drogon
und wog 250 kg.
Und trotzdem konnte er fliegen.
Das ist schon echt heftig.
Deshalb dachte man lange,
dass die riesigen Flugsaurier
nicht flugfähig sind.
Wie heute der Vogel Strauß.
Dann gab es aber
2 Wissenschaftler aus den USA.
Die veröffentlichten
2010 eine Studie.
Darin belegten sie,
dass Quetzalcoatlus fliegen konnte.
Wie sind sie darauf gekommen?
Das finde ich cool.
Als richtige Wissenschaftler
haben sie eine Vorannahme überprüft.
Man ging davon aus,
dass Flugsaurier-Knochen
aufgebaut sind wie die von Vögeln.
Sie haben sich CT-Scans
von Flugsaurier-Knochen angeschaut.
Und stellten fest, nein, sie sind
wie Säugetier-Knochen aufgebaut.
Damit sind sie
dreimal stabiler als die von Vögeln.
Oh yeah.
Beim Quetzalcoatlus
mussten die Knochen 250 kg tragen.
Die Wissenschaftler entdeckten,
dass noch viel mehr Gewicht
möglich gewesen wäre.
Wow, voll gut auch für uns jetzt.
Denn das heißt nicht nur,
dass es schon mal Kreaturen gab,
die mit extrem viel Gewicht
abgehoben sind.
Sondern,
dass theoretisch auch Drachen
damit die Lüfte erklimmen können.
Finde ich mega-gut.
Das heißt, dass nur noch
eine letzte Frage übrigbleibt.
*spannende Musik*
Um Feuer zu machen,
brauchen wir nur 3 Dinge.
Wir brauchen einen Funken
oder Wärme als Energie-Eintrag.
Damit die Verbrennung startet.
Wir brauchen einen Brennstoff,
der verbrennen kann, und Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff
ist in der Luft reichlich vorhanden.
Drachen haben sicher Riesen-Lungen,
mit denen sie das anfeuern können.
Wie wir entzündete Grillkohle
anfeuern, damit sie glüht.
Da müssen wir uns
keine Sorgen machen.
Aber beim Brennstoff müssen wir
überlegen, was wir nehmen könnten.
Da habe ich direkt an das hier,
an Bärlapp-Sporen gedacht.
Bei Feuerkünstlern
unter diesem Namen bekannt.
Die sorgen
für eine richtige Stichflamme.
Die Frage an dich ist,
hast du Lust, Feuer zu spucken?
Ich bin jetzt nicht wie der Hound
und habe Angst vor Feuer.
Aber ich würde dir
mal den Vortritt lassen.
Aber dann nimmst du die Schale.
Ich habe schon was vorbereitet.
Guck mal, ich habe einen
schönen Drogon-Kopf mitgebracht.
Hier hinten ist ein Schlauch dran.
Da würde ich was von dem Lycopodium,
von den Bärlapp-Sporen reinpacken.
Dann würde ich sagen, Karim,
wir schalten das Ding mal scharf.
Es gibt eine Fernbedienung dazu.
Du darfst jetzt auf A drücken
und den Funken entfachen.
Du musst runterzählen, 3, 2, 1.
Okay ... 3 ... 2 ... 1.
*dreimal explosiver Knall*
*Jubel*
*explosiver Knall*
*Jack lacht.*
Okay, krass.
Krass, oder?
Das Coole daran ist, dass eigentlich
Lycopodium an sich gar nicht brennt.
Wenn man das hier
mit dem Feuerzeug anzündet,
dann sieht man, dass es kaum ... au.
Also, das Feuerzeug wird heiß,
aber das Zeug an sich brennt kaum.
Es kommt wirklich auf diese Wolke an.
Es funktioniert,
weil sich beim Reinpusten
ein Gemisch aus Luft und
den winzigen Bärlapp-Sporen bildet.
Dadurch wird die Oberfläche
extrem vergrößert.
Dann reicht schon ein kleiner Funke,
um das Gemisch zu entzünden
und eine Explosion auszulösen.
Das ist eine mega-gute Erklärung
für den Brennstoff.
Aber das hieße ja, dass sie davon
große Mengen in sich lagern müssten,
etwa in einer Blase,
und das auch noch trocken.
Es würde auch
diese Szene nicht erklären.
*Explosion*
*Viserion schreit.*
Als Buch-Fan muss ich sagen, dass
diese Szene für mich kein Canon ist.
Abgesehen davon sieht man hier,
dass Viserion
vom Speer am Hals getroffen wird.
Dann gibt es eine Explosion.
Das passt nicht zusammen,
da Bärlapp-Sporen nicht explodieren.
Sie entzünden sich nicht mal,
sie müssen Feinstaub-Form haben.
Okay, dann haut es nicht hin.
Vielleicht ein Gas als Brennstoff?
Zum Beispiel?
Methan zum Beispiel?
Das kennen wir von Kühen.
Sie produzieren 1 l davon am Tag.
Das klingt nicht viel.
Aber mit 1 l Methan kann ich
1 l Wasser um 4.000°C erhitzen.
Schon
eine ordentliche Brenn-Leistung.
Das Problem mit der Theorie ist nur,
dass das Methan von Bakterien
im Pansen der Kühe kommt.
Weil sie Pflanzen versetzen.
Und die Drachen fressen ja Fleisch.
Okay,
und wenn die Kamera es nicht filmt?
Wenn Drachen Pflanzen fressen,
und wir sehen es nur nicht?
Wir sehen ja nicht alles
in "Game of Thrones".
Wie John Snow auf Toilette gehen.
- Weil das dort sehr gefährlich ist.
Autsch.
Aber wenn wir schon bei Fiktion sind,
lasst uns
bei "Cinema Strikes Back" nachfragen,
welche Behelfslösung es geben könnte.
Welche Erklärung könnte es noch
für Drachen-Feuer geben?
Im einschlägigen Fandom heißt es,
Drachen produzieren ihren Feuer-Atem
durch Aussondern zweier Chemikalien
an der Rückseite ihrer Kehle.
Treffen diese beiden
explosiven Substanzen aufeinander,
entlädt sich
die kombinierte Reaktion
in einem
zielgerichteten Feuerstrahl.
Eine clevere und plausible Theorie.
Sie hätte auch den Vorteil,
dass wir den Funken nicht bräuchten.
Das gibt es sogar in der Realität
unter dieser Bezeichnung.
Sie wird z.B.
als Raketen-Treibstoff eingesetzt.
Verbinden sich die Flüssigkeiten,
entzünden sie sich.
Das Problem ist, dass sie sehr dicht
und damit sehr schwer sind.
Das beißt sich mit dem Fliegen.
Zudem sind sie korrodierend
und auch giftig.
Ob man als Drache
sowas in sich drin haben möchte?
Dann würde es auch in ihm drin
schon total heiß werden.
Also, wie schützt denn
der Drachen seinen Rachen?
Durch schlechte Reime.
Rachen nicht, aber ein Beispiel
ist der Bombardierkäfer.
Er kann extrem hohe Temperaturen
in seinem Körpers überstehen.
Fühlt sich der Käfer bedroht,
mischt er 2 Stoffe in einer Kammer.
Die Beschichtung der Kammer
fungiert als Katalysator.
Und bewirkt eine exotherme Reaktion,
die genug Wärme erzeugt,
um die Chemikalien-Mischung
zum Kochen zu bringen.
Diese
ungefähr 100°C heiße Flüssigkeit
wird vom Hinterteil des Käfers
heftig ausgestoßen.
Der durch die Ausdehnung
entstehende Druck
versperrt die Öffnungen der Kammer
und schützt die Organe des Käfers.
Beim Drachen muss es ja
definitiv durch ihn durch.
Also, an wichtigen Organen vorbei,
an Arterien und durch den Rachen.
Das haut dann nicht hin.
Und Drachen-Feuer ist viel heißer,
wenn es Mauern schmelzen lässt.
Einen Schutz dagegen
sehen wir nicht.
Also können wir festhalten,
ein Drache hätte die Möglichkeit,
einen biologischen Brennstoff
zu erzeugen oder zu speichern.
Er hätte auch die Möglichkeit,
diesen Brennstoff zu entzünden.
Aber ein Drache hat keine Chance,
sich gegen sein eigenes Feuer
zu schützen.
Karim, danke, dass du da warst.
Es hat Spaß gemacht.
Danke für die Einladung und den Dreh
am heißesten Tag des Jahres.
"Das Lied von Schweiß und Feuer".
Habt ihr Bock auf Karims Content?
Das solltet ihr.
Dann guckt mal in die Infobox.
Da haben wir den Link
zu seinem Kanal hingepackt.
Unser Dank geht auch
an "Cinema Strikes Back",
die uns mal wieder
tolle Fiktions-Fakten erklärt haben.
Auch den Link zu denen
packe ich euch unten mit rein.
Ihr könnt mir noch sagen,
was eurer Lieblings-Drache ist.
Nicht nur aus "Game of Thrones", auch
aus "Drachenzähmen leicht gemacht".
Oder aus einem anderen Franchise.
Lasst mir einen Kommentar dazu da.
Vergesst bitte auf gar keinen Fall,
diesen Kanal zu abonnieren.
Und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns wieder
zu neuen feurigen Episoden.
Vielleicht mit Karim,
wahrscheinlich mit mir.
Bis bald, ciao, ciao.
♪ Everybody.
♪ Yeah.
♪ Klick diese Videos.
Große Echsen gibt's auch
bei "Godzilla" und "Jurassic World".
Copyright UT: MDR 2022